[Musik]
was überhaupt netz bekommen beim neuen
video seine spieler immer diese sich
rechtfertigen was genau ich hab drei
haare gewachsen und ich muss nicht mehr
dabei es ist einfacher als stressig
wasser wieder sechs turnieren und um
rollen wegen neuer boss aber ich muss
natürlich geborgen video haben und
deswegen habe ich mich jetzt noch
hingesetzt und überlegt was kann zu
machen nicht überraschen der schönen
zeit da komm ich richtig gerne videos
argumenten mirka und ich habe mich heute
viel mit ich hab doch ein altencelle den
kindern fast niemand von euch und auch
diese jetzt auch genau ein video ja und
ich glaube er weiß jetzt sein müssen
ich hab mir zunächst mal keine alten
wieder mehr von mir angerufen und ihr
euch gezeigt bekommen habe ich mir
wieder sagt dass sie die überschrift
echt wirklich alle zusammen meinen
freunden sitzen zusammen und es ist
einfach für mich könnte
deswegen will ich eigentlich gar nicht
lange da wie ich würde sagen wir fangen
einfach mal an und wenn ich das
demnächst nochmal machen soll jetzt
einfach mal doch nach oben da weil man
sich das ja ich würde sagen meinte ich
mir dann mal das nächste video oder
alten video vom hersteller und paar
witzige und ja auch die plätze fertig
anschauen und so
falls habe ich mal wieder vorkommt also
erstmal kurz bieten vermag von jedermann
habe ich vier folgen macht da bin ich
einfach wegen meiner freunde an getreten
und wir haben einfach die dümmsten
aufgabe gemacht diese aufgaben nichts zu
tun wir haben eine kino ohne messer
wurde er das ganze ausgehen
[Musik]
bekommen
irgendwann spaß die sagt im hintergrund
der ureinwohner optionalen mein kollege
hat so zeller der sich heute eigentlich
auch in der zweiten runde
ich musste mich sogar ein ich muss ein
video drehen meine sachen packe die
werden ausgepackt und dabei noch essen
wie ein mädchen
[Musik]
ein
rom
kommen
nun macht jetzt gleich von darf bis nach
seinem beinbruch vom hinauf ein bein und
einfach nur ein bisschen
[Musik]
acht mal bitte oft im hintergrund junge
rief die zurückgeblieben
[Musik]
er muss jetzt gerade da abliefern im
abstellraum oder so das heißt sein kann
so ein typ
und da darf man nicht rein
also schlug mir halt ein appell hat man
ja gesehen habt in ihm hat sich die
wirklich geschmeckt
einfach fiel komplett zurückgebliebene
vollidioten die ihr heute machen unser
youtube ist er aber wieder knapp 140
leistung 30 bis gleich ich fand mich
wird heutzutage würde ich sowas niemals
leisten würden durchs kinderzimmer
kürzlich gleichen schritt bis leistung
mit zehn account video ich habe wie
gesagt bei fehler vielleicht gucke mir
das nächste eigentlich von mir ein
schlepper in die kommentare auf nämlich
früher mit und wir denken dass man
morgen wieder ab montag um 38 kommt und
richtig geiles video also freue mich auf
jeden fall auch nicht woche ich wünsche
euch schönen tag und kommt auf jeden
fall am 15
c&a oberhausen zentrum von künftigen
sitzen dem treffen ich freue mich auf
jeden fall vorrang